you decide after the o4 olympics you're
going pro got your taste of your first
olympic gold yes then we're going to
work beijing right yeah what was that
preparation going into that where were
you at mentally and physically coming to
08 the heavy favorite to win gold up
until that point i was mentally and
physically feeling really well and then
the hardest thing happened in my whole
life right before the olympics i found
out i was pregnant
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today
oh we got a track star
what's up with you i'm good master how
are you living i'm glad you come out of
the pool listen i'm excited you think
i'm just a track star i'm master of the
pool table
okay no i'm joking i'm joking
don't make me break please you're gonna
be good okay oh no you trust me you are
breaking though i am right here
give you the power use your left hand to
guide it
did something happen
not really
okay now something happened now
something happened how did you get a
trek i was born in jamaica and track and
field is the most popular sport in
jamaica and so growing up it was track
all the time how did you make the
decision between running for jamaica or
running for the us i want to say it was
like bigger and you know than it was but
to be very honest for me it was more
about like where my friends were and i
didn't realize that i was going to upset
so many people at the time because it
was really just meant to be like a
personal thing but it really made a lot
of waves in the track community what was
the response yeah so
[Laughter]
would you imagine that i make my first
world junior team and for the very first
time in history the meet is in jamaica i
said oh my lord damn so here i am making
my first team usa and going back to the
track that i actually fell in love with
track on in front of a crowd of people
who really love the sport you know it's
not like they might forget and so on
team captain my team voted me flag but i
said oh no no no oh y'all
you're only about to have them
tomatoes
[Laughter]
so a lot of anticipation excitement for
us to come to jamaica and the first day
i walk out for the pre-limbs from under
the like stadium they boo me the whole
crowd the whole crowd because it was
like 90 jamaicans in the crowd and they
say my name and they're like sonia
richards representing team usa boo
and i'm like i'm 16. were you expecting
that earlier not at all not at all so
when you heard the booze as you were
coming how did you feel heartbroken
because i'm a people pleaser like i love
people
i loved my country still and i was
really young
and you know to be very honest like when
i go back and think about my
championship runs i think that that
moment made it really hard for me to
compete about best in championships
because i always remembered the booze
and the disappointment how'd you deal
with it honestly it took me many years
to realize that i had the problem you
know and i ended up getting a sports
psychologist in 2009 like seven eight
years later that i finally got with
somebody and that was a game changer for
me i got the sports psychologist and i
realized damn this whole time i have a
track coach like i know how important it
is to have somebody help me physically
like why would i not invest in a mental
coach i've been seeing a therapist now
for four years there's always that
barrier that kind of tells you you don't
need it yeah it's your shot i think so
let's see what you got let's see what
i'm working with over here i wish we had
a track and some spikes because
this ain't it
so then you decide after the o4 olympics
you go on pro yep got your taste in your
first olympic gold yeah then we're going
to work beijing right yeah beijing where
were you at
mentally and physically going into 08 um
so 2005 i'm world number one 2006 i
break the american record which still
stands today 48.70 007 i actually get
diagnosed with a rare autoimmune disease
which kind of knocks me off my block a
little bit but i'm able to overcome that
it was really hard i got diagnosed with
a disease called base chest disease
which is like extremely rare but i had
severe mouth ulcers skin lesion and like
extra fatigue which you do not need in
the 400
and i went to like nine different
doctors because nobody could tell what
was going on with me it was a really
difficult time but i was still able to
rebound 2007. i think i was still world
number one actually no seven so i come
into o8 the heavy favorite to win gold
up until that point i was mentally and
physically feeling really well and then
the hardest thing happened in my whole
life right before the olympics i found
out i was pregnant wow and i literally
have an abortion the day before i fly to
beijing people will say you know just
have an abortion well you don't just
have an abortion it was
extremely traumatic for me and i go to
the olympics and i literally feel like i
don't deserve to be there and so to have
to make a choice like that where it's
like i knew i wanted to have a family
but i wasn't ready my husband and i
weren't ready and i knew i went to an
olympic gold medalist do i make this
choice like to do that yeah i went into
the olympics with a very heavy heart and
then also too i never even thought about
it in the moment but also physically
what was happening to me too like they
tell you to take two weeks off and i'm
like in hardcore training right after
like i land in beijing and i'm at work
also the physical toll that it took on
me too
was difficult as well so
it wasn't in a good mental space in
beijing at all
and you went to beijing yeah you said
you needed two weeks off physically your
body did you didn't do that
how was your body responding that the
night before the final i couldn't sleep
i was in so much turmoil mentally
physically and so when i finished with
the bronze medal it's like
everything was wrong right like here i
am i just had an abortion and so that
was really hard for me and really
crushing and i remember going away from
that experience and i want to share this
with you two master i was i'm in china
right and
we stay in the village with the athletes
and after the olympic race you know
we're supposed to go back to the village
and i was like there's no way i'm going
back so i'm like ballin can't really see
i jump on this bus and i end up i'm on
the wrong bus and i feel completely lost
like lost physically lost spiritually
emotionally and i'm kind of crashing on
the ground crying
and i tell you no lie i feel the
presence of god like hug me in the
streets of china and like he was like i
love you and you're forgiven you know
and i was like wow the love of god is
never ending you know
and this guy comes over to me and he's
an american and he recognized me he's
like are you okay are you okay and he
helped me call my mom and i get on the
bus and i go home to my family and that
was kind of the start of the healing for
me from that whole experience you know
great deal of resilience display right
there thank you
cool i think zeo shot on my shot my
shots go ahead i don't think either way
i got the ball in the hole yes i think
we're just getting lost in conversation
okay all right i like that too that's
better for me
what
[Music]
so we know you're nice on the spikes
we're going to see how nice you are over
here on papa shout out okay let's see 60
seconds i'm gonna ask you questions as
you shoot okay you ready let's do it
three two
one who are you listening to before
racing i used to love young jockeys
going down
funniest teammate you ever had hands
down raising mcintosh favorite olympics
you were in 2012 two gold
best track athlete in history usain bolt
and shelly and fraser price individual
400 or 4x4 relay individual honey jerk
chicken curry goat i like to say curry
chicken curry chicken yeah i don't eat
gold i love curry chicken best track in
the world race i love hayward's field in
eugene oregon and during switzerland the
one athlete that are alive you'd want to
meet i want to meet
michael jordan favorite pair kicks you
home air max is air max queen over here
okay i'll see you craziest partier on
team usa the craziest part here ryan
lochte two
one
best olympian
perk you know most people have never
seen olympic gold medal before so like
when you have it they're like
and you got four of them jones
oh man i had the best time thank you for
coming to pool hall appreciate you for
jumping on with us thanks for having me